[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits I'm Rhett and
I'm link this week at the roundtable of
dim lighting we're asking the question
do we like getting recognized in public
hmm but before we get into that
discussion we wanna let you know that we
are going on tour and we're gonna
announce all the dates with the rest
weird like the way you said tour 2019 I
want to make it make it clear who or
that this is it guys these are the only
dates for 2019 this may be the only
dates for some time okay we don't know
if we're gonna be going out again in
2020 we don't know so this might be your
last chance definitely to see this show
a night of music and comedy we're gonna
be in Las Vegas on June 21st
Salt Lake City on June 22nd Denver on
June 23rd Milwaukee on the 25th
Indianapolis on the 26th Detroit on the
27th Omaha on the 29th and Minneapolis
on the 30th so that's coming up that's
coming up into June all right and then I
got some fall dates starting September
4th we're gonna be on Hugh on Houston
we're gonna be auditing on who's
September 4th New Orleans September 5th
Birmingham Alabama September 6
Jacksonville Florida September 7th Tampa
Florida September 8th didn't skipping
down to the end of November Albuquerque
New Mexico November 20th Phoenix
21st Sacramento California November 22nd
and Valley Center California as center
of the Vera's Resort on November 23rd
rhettandlink live.com get your tickets I
I want to get an update yeah I've kind
of gotten the update I want you to give
the listener an update on your mimic
diet thing because I didn't you know
anytime you do like a what I'll call an
experiment on yourself I don't know how
you would describe it I describe it as a
failed experiment okay especially if
it's a failure I want to hear about it I
want this hear about it I want to hear
about it twice I'll put it to
that way okay quick refresh it was a
diet designed by a professor who got
together with the people at the
anti-aging Institute or something that's
named something like that and created a
diet that tricks your body into thinking
that it's fasting so you get the
benefits the physiological benefits of
fasting without going on completely
nothing but it's for me for a big for a
big man like me what happen is I'm just
adding to the big man montage 700
calories is not a lot so I lost nine
pounds which not hard to do when you're
as big as I am but I actually had the
benefit of how much did you weigh I
probably like to fifteen but when I
started okay and I the reason I know
exactly how much I lost and the
composition of what I lost is because I
did that thing they have at my gym
called the in body or you get up there
and you hold the thing and it gives a
very specific analysis of your I don't I
mean I trust that it's accurate is one
in my gym to you stand on the thing you
stand on the thing barefoot yeah and
then you hold these things on your
thumbs and you hold your arms out like
that yeah and you don't move and then it
gives you like this is how much muscle
you have in your right arm and your left
arm in the oh yeah and then it gives you
your BMI and all that so before
so I just happened that I did it right
before and after and we were looking at
it and my trainer was like you lost nine
pounds and then she was like six pounds
of water dang that's that doesn't sound
like the right thing to lose two pounds
of muscle okay and one pound of fat yeah
so mission not accomplished not good
I lost more of what I want less of what
I don't want and what and I want water
and I she was she it wasn't that I had
dehydrated myself it was something about
the fact that your nutrients in able
water and taken to your muscle
or whatever but the thing that I also
noticed is that you know have all kinds
of issues with my back like all up and
down the spine and like muscle stuff
that happens because of weird things in
my discs and all that got exacerbated to
the point that like it was tightening up
because you body needs stuff it needs
nutrients especially if you've got like
you're kind of borderline about to go
into like a muscle spasm at any moment
and so it but after a week of just
regular eating everything is back to
normal you gained nine pounds well I
haven't done that I'm just saying it
like I feel good again my back is is
good so are you doing are you still
doing intermittent fasting
yeah I'm still doing that because that
just is not that man yet that is a just
as a lifestyle well some people are like
we don't promote diets especially ones
that don't work yeah in the family say I
was I was reading the fasting wasn't a
diet soda it was it was a fasting period
for very specific reasons and it wasn't
so it wasn't so I could lose weight that
wasn't why I was doing it I'm doing it
because I wanted to have something I
could go back to him like a quarterly
basis if it did have good results and
those those numbers then it would I'll
do it again but so you do recommend it
and you maile use a coat ear to lose
nine pounds of the wrong stuff well yeah
you could we shouldn't be throwing our
coupon code for like bunk if you want to
lose one pound of fat in eight pounds of
muscle and water okay you've got too
much water and muscles don't use k know
who you are too much muscle in water
yeah so we're gonna to well first of all
I got a cold like I'm three days into
this thing yeah I actually it's all play
though it's a pet peeve of mine this is
a bad time to get a cold this is a tough
time to get a cold what do you mean
transitioning from spring to summer it's
just it makes you feel like you're out
of sync with with nature I'm gonna be
I'm gonna be good in about two days
because I've been doing this thing
called a mimic diet Mimico fasting diet
it's called in it so that's different
than the fasting mimicking diet oh yes
it must be that I've not been doing
you'll gain muscle mass I'm trying to
nap it's a pet peeve of mine for
podcasters to like go on and on about
how their voice is different and like
apologizing about how they're sick I
think it's good dig now I just want to
acknowledge it got some Kleenex down
here but yeah we're going to talk about
a question we get often I think when
we're being recognized at least I know I
do is do you get recognized often and I
think the implied follow-up question is
how do you feel about that or this as
it's happening so um and also think I
want to know if they are the the like a
special source of something like maybe
he doesn't get recognized at all right
and I've made his week so I want to get
into that but something happened to me
that I wanted I've been saving this
story to share with you and you and you
too Jacob I was pointing at the at the
camera which represents one lawyer
listener but then you know but also
Jacob now the corner of his eye he saw
me point now I am pointing it to you
that's what it feels like for me to
point is you incidentally pointing is a
part of this story oh gosh I'm not good
it's fine
this happened in the context of when we
were taking care of my father-in-law
Luis at the hospital and I took a break
and I came home and I was exhausted and
I you know I was gonna take a nap but
now I was like you know what it would be
therapeutic for me to walk the dog and
I'm gonna make Lily come with me
so come along so that I can spend some
time with her cuz I just wasn't seeing
the kids as much in in that phase of
caring for him in the hospital
right so we went out for a walk and
we're walking down the street and I'm I
remember the doggy bags a lot of times I
don't remember to doggie bags I'm glad I
did because when you don't what do you
do I'll use like if Jade poops I'll use
like a leaf I'll find a big leaf and use
it as like a glove and then I'll just
throw it all into the woods
what woods well though the woods like on
my walk like trees not someone's front
yard there's not a lot of woods
around here so you're throwing it all
that somebody's property man I mean
there are trees in like little wooded
areas like unmowed just areas of people
jihad okay yeah people's your hearts
okay but the wooded parts of people's
yards that they never go into the thing
about Jade is she likes to like we'll be
walking all of a sudden I realize up the
lease is getting taught and I look back
there and she's popping a squat in the
middle of the street yeah Barbara does
the same like she doesn't go to the
grass in somebody's yard she's very
respectful of that she she goes to be
like not even in on the lane of the
street where she's walking like on the
edge she like go to the middle of the
road and like I want to have a no I want
to have a wide berth as I that's funny
because birth barbie is the same thing
and I always thought that that was ID I
was doing something wrong like it just
she's stupid like she's not she doesn't
understand we never told her that she
shouldn't do that that that yeah it
feels more natural to do it on the grass
or some dirt but it's easier to clean up
when it's on the concrete I like I like
to like throw some dirt or some leaves
on it before I pick it up so I do not
like it being on the dirt I don't like
just grab it you're like mr. Leone
throwing sawdust on vomit yeah he was
the janitor at our booth Creek
Elementary may he rest in peace
graiman so anyway she pops a squat in
the middle of the street and I'm like
you know then I'm cleaning it up with
the bag you know your pertain you know
how to do this put your hand in the bag
then you grab it and you turn it around
in your hand but it still is really
bothersome to me it's not go it's so
warm and I feel like it's coming through
this bag in some way that's why probably
is a little bit nature sawdust like
whatever I can find I like try to let
that some mulch from somebody's yard
yeah yeah yeah a little bit of moss yeah
I they don't need this yeah
have you seen me do this yeah your act
the way the objects in your story as is
as if you're on a hike in Yosemite but
really you're in the suburbs of Los
Angeles where there's no woods it's just
trees in people's yards and the mulch
that they've still carefully arranged
and you're using it I don't miss the
less sawdust so then I'm carrying this
bag around
we turned the corner and we're going up
the street and I you know I will say at
this point because this is the point of
the street where it usually happens
there's this car that's typically parked
there that has a vanity license plate
you know me and my bumper stumpers I've
always noticed the vanity license plates
and there's there's a lights plate says
mr. noodle which for those of you who
don't know mr. noodle is a live-action
mime character in Elmo's World
the Sesame Street series and he was kind
of like a clown without makeup he would
do like clownish things and and then
there mr. noodle had a brother mr.
noodle
and like Elmo would voice over this
whole like mr. noodle you remember you
know mr. noodle right never have washed
it Lilly was really into Elmo I think um
Lincoln was I saw I saw the controversy
coming never let my kids I just sensed
it never let him let him watch it
oh I separate the man from the puppet
and mr. Cole thing to do when his hand
isn't it pretty much becomes a dead Elmo
when you okay good well I have no
response to that
I'm just going to tell my story now so
III will clarify that there are no
controversies that I know of associated
with mr. noodle or his brother mr.
Newton though with that name you would
think there would be if anybody's
problematic probably mr. noodle that mr.
noodles brother mr. noodle was played by
the guy from evening shade who who was
also in the Green Mile
but I can't be more specific about what
his name is but any white mustache so
there's license plate mr. noodle and
then sometimes but on a rarer occasion
I'll see another car and it says the
license plate said dr. noodle I'm like
oh there's a family of noodles that live
around here what in for so for like two
years
I've seen these vanity license plates
it's so it's just a part of my life and
like sometimes what you know will point
it out there's there's mr. noodles Park
there again
so I'm walking that's just a little
background so we're walking now I've got
this poop bag in my hand a lily and I
walking we're I'm catching her up on the
situation at the hospital and everything
we're having a great conversation but
I'm bothered by the fact that I haven't
even completed 30% of this dog walk and
I'm already holding poop in a bag I do
not like being that guy like I judge
heavily the people I see walking their
dog with like a big sack of poop in
their hand it's just like you got to
offload that what a loser but I also I
hate seeing poop bags just laying around
it's like we are we're humans you know
we're at a point on the food chain where
we need to love our earth to the point
where we can't just throw plastic poop
bags down just because of pride you see
people throw plastic poop bags not I I
see them laying down and see evidence
that they've been left places like when
you go on hikes around LA there's people
who were like drop their poop bag and
you know what they're thinking
they're thinking I hate walking around
with a poop bag when I come back down
the trail I'll pick it up and throw it
away no you don't and then when they see
you they're like well that could be
anybody
oh yeah you conveniently forget about it
I don't want to be that guy so I'm gonna
catch-22 situation so I tell Lily I'm
like Lily when I spot a trash can you're
gonna get rid of this thing now the
trash should come recently so mote it
wasn't like all everyone's trash cans
were out but there are the stragglers
there's some stragglers and you're
looking for that 1 out of 10 so I'm like
we're looking for stragglers we round
this corner and go down this other
dead-end street I'm talking to her like
this it's just like looking at me like
are you okay and let me say before you
before you proceed I believe in this
I'll just I'll just say that I believe
in what you're about to do here's what I
believe in okay I'm like because it's a
it we're all humans it's pote it's a
public service yes it's your trash can
but I'm not changing the dynamics of
your trash you know I'm not throwing a
chair in there you don't I'm saying or
this body it's a bag of poop it doesn't
change anything you should be okay with
it if when you're 34 your subject okay
I'm glad
you're backing me up but subject to some
specific key points that I believe and
that I wanted to relay to Lily because I
needed her help I think the first thing
is you got to pick the right trash can
there's a green one
for of course there's a blue one for
recycling there's a black one and I'm
like Lily look up there I see some
stragglers there's three trash cans what
I want you to do and this is my second
point any begging your daughter I want
we got it the second point is we got to
be clandestine well you gotta be you
gotta be sneaky even though I completely
believe in it you still gotta because
you never know how the person is gonna
feel looking out their window and seeing
somebody open their trash can and make a
little deposit yeah you don't know if
they're gonna run out with some sort of
a firearm or at least I doubt that would
happen armed to the gills with insults
that could happen you know in front of
my daughter and my beloved Beast
cuz I will say that if I saw it happen
you'd be mad you would feel anger
instinctively but I wouldn't say
anything because I'd be like you know
what but for all the reasons I just said
but I understand heart rate would go up
in tendency to do some breathing that
tendency to be protective of your trash
I get it it's your domain it's not
logical but I get it something like Lily
what I want we're gonna subtly scoot
over to the left side of the road as
we're walking we're not gonna stop
walking I want you to go up to the trash
can I want you to gently lift the lid
like three inches all right you don't
have to open it all the way I'm talking
to her this way maybe over instruction
but I'm like I just want you to just
give me a little poop bag gap and then
I'm gonna I'm gonna come in I'm gonna
swoop in I'm just gonna i'ma throw it in
there and then gently let go you
would've made this a two-person job and
not be a two-person job if I was there I
would have been like listen bad idea
listen you short-sighted amateur I'm
walking a dog with a leash in one hand I
got poop in a bag in the other hand and
I got a daughter with two free hands
like I got to teach her the ways man
this is this is a teachable moment this
is less about what I need and more about
what she needs I would give her the poop
and let her do the whole shebang that's
just what I would have done
well that's because two hands you're a
cruel unfeeling father lift with one
deposit were the other and she's also a
young woman I leave
sample gives her she's gonna get a
little more leeway they're gonna be a
little bit less likely to come out
cussing or for the firearm little less
like so there's still a likelihood that
your daughter could be blasted with poop
bag insults and hey if you're fine with
that your daughter can be thrown to the
Wolves then she could be taught a lesson
then that would be the lesson how do you
deal with that so I'm like I just need
three inches in three seconds and I'll
take care of the rest
and she's like dad this isn't a heist
yeah I'm with her I'm like just going
we're almost there just don't just just
do the plan and I'm talking like this
now and they probably look suspicious
and at the leg and then she she grabs
the green and then she like she gets she
gives me three inches on the black one
and I just make the deposit and then we
we immediately swing back over to the
other side of the road and I'm like yes
I think I literally outloud said yes
yeah and at that moment I looked up and
I saw a car with a person inside of it
and the door was open I was like nope he
didn't see us he was he was like in his
car detailing his - but he was the owner
of the trashcan he was on the same side
of the trashcan he there I would say
most likely the man in the car cleaning
the - was the owner of the three trash
cans yes mm-hmm
a panic for a moment but as I said it
said it before it not really the owner
they're on loan from the from the city
he's renting it yeah so I mean we're
salt we're all paying for put yourself
in his shoes right I was a bit afraid
until I realized and I told love that he
didn't see it he didn't see anything
we succeeded we are amazing you know I
hope Jade craps again right now so we
can just do it again it was exhilarating
it's like on the edge the dude was like
rubbing his dash down with like some
armor-all situation it was like he was
like me like when I first got my 1987
Nissan pickup and I thought that I was
gonna
exit and it was already so old that when
I waxed it like it basically just took
the paint off and saw like crow mother
yeah like like shear metal the dude was
going at it he never looked up I was
like oh it's your fault man you're too
into your - to see who's making the
stash in your pan what happened though
okay
yeah I should get on with this story so
I walked by and we go all the way to the
end of the road and then we have to turn
around and we're walking back and I'm
like oh it the guys still there and then
I noticed from this new vantage point I
can see the license plate on the car and
it says dr. noodle oh gosh
so then without seeing anything to Lily
as I'm as we're walking by again his
doors open one foots out and he's still
on that - just grinding it it's just
like so dirty - shiny - by this point we
get up next to him and I'm probably as
far from here to that wall so like I
don't know seven feet away and at that
point without really planning out what
I'm gonna do I just went with the
feeling mmm yeah I you know I was I was
feeling I was feeling on top of the
world after what had happened and I
point at him and I say you must be dr.
noodle he he looks up from his - and the
look on his face went from surprised
someone speaking to me
- like jaw-dropping amazement and he
says you know me and then before I could
say anything in response he said I know
you - and I said and I never stopped
walking what I never stopped walking and
I said cool man you have a good day
then Lily leans over as we're still
walking she leaned you're afraid of him
because of what you had done that's why
you didn't stop
Lily leaned over and she said I was like
your I was like we just met dr. noodle
that's what's happening then we walked
around the corner well who the hell is
dr. noodle well he's that guy but here's
the thing he had this amazing to look on
his face and it was as if I'd gone up to
Clark Kent on the streets of Metropolis
with his glasses on and I said you must
be Superman it was like it was one of
those oh you know me it was like what it
it's like when someone has a nametag on
and they forget and you think you're
cute because you're like Steve what's up
and they're like you know right but
people don't typically say you know me
but then he also he but you know he also
knew me since then I guess from the
internet since then he has realized why
you said that I walked around there what
do you mean because of his license
yeah he realized it but he did know me I
guess from why did you know you get you
didn't stop subconsciously because I was
walking a dog I wasn't standing a dog
you did you may not even realize why you
didn't stop you didn't stop because of
you felt guilt over the poop they went
around the corner and guess what we saw
we saw in the other car and from that
vantage point it said mr. noodle we were
like look Lily one down one to go one
day we might just get to meet her mr.
noodle oh that's the same same house
right yeah but I'd like to think there's
a doctor and a mr. noodle living there
there's two cars but you met the doctor
I'm at the doctor I'm just really
interested in I don't who's doc he
obviously does something's a - doctor
he's a car doctor update to the story
just to provide a little color comment
what I'm saying is you could have found
out by just stopping I didn't want to
have a conversation right I was just
being nice I think I made his day
okay maybe he made yours through that
story I was walking Jade yesterday and I
walked past dr. noodle and dadgum if he
wasn't out there again second time and
guess what he was doing he had the hood
open of the same car he made me man he
was he was cleaning the engine he's
gonna he's gonna sell that car cuz
cleaning the engine doesn't do anything
except make people think that your car
is cool now I'm saying
IV but not cleaning this engine is I
think he just had another 10,000 miles
he's a shine doctor he's a doctor of car
shine you know me what kind of car is it
I know you - is it like a car that he
was like into a car show he was like in
a course yeah he's going to the Accord
car shows anyway he he recognized me and
I will say that's probably the most
enjoyment I've ever had about over being
recognized spoiler alert oh it's all
downhill from there well in the negative
maybe maybe not cuz I don't want to be
negative about being recognized but we
must wrestle you know what we're not
we're gonna be honest about being
recognized but first we're gonna let you
know that you can get a notebook or two
dramatic leaning inwards
he got he got the good mythical Snoke
book it's a notebook in a sketchbook in
one and this is just the mythical
notebook blank pages Tablo Rosa just
like my brain now this one I was told
not to open it up because and show you
because it's from Zak but I was gonna
read a little bit of Zach's diary people
knew it was just a test people actually
know he I mean there's like something at
the beginning but I'm not gonna look at
it or read it it was just a bit this it
wasn't this designed by our very own
Caitlin yeah
she drew she draws this on every single
one every single fun is hand-drawn it's
quite a deal know she'd hand drew it
once and then we printed it on all the
rest of them so record your thoughts
your feelings in your life with ass
notebook as mythical dot snore snore
oh we got a sleep study going yeah for
the mythical sleep study mythic oh gosh
open this pod guys is not a sleep study
do I have a Kleenex or snot on my face
hey you got yeah you got some kind of
kind of yeah but don't you know don't
door don't - it don't do it like dr.
noodle rubs his - cuz eventually it'll
turn red you don't wanna overdo it just
put some armor law armor all on there
protect yourself oh god yeah okay so
we're gonna explore the the dynamic we
you know we talked about this from time
to time if you if you've listened to the
show for a while you know that we talk
we tell the story or two about being
recognized in certain places and what we
said and what the person said we might
reach read a few of those but we're
doing it in the context of answering
this question of like what is it what
does it do for us like mentally
emotionally what is it like to be it to
be recognized in public how do we deal
with it what do we think about it and
this could come across as a little bit
like self aggrandizing I think is the
word that you used when we were thinking
about doing this yeah when I pitched the
topic let's do something self
aggrandizing yeah you know like talk
about getting how often we recognized
yeah but we're doing it in the because
we we have this conversation and I think
that because you you listener or perhaps
the kind of person that if you saw us in
public you might feel like you had to
dr. noodle us and if you if you if you
do then this might give a little
perspective and I don't know where it's
gonna go I don't wait there's no agenda
we're not like trying to land it some
sort of like public recognition ethic or
anything maybe we will by the end of
this but I have I have a little story
that I can start with that happen
recently and I think it kind of feeds
into a part of my perspective on this
and that is I think part of the positive
for me and this is just a totally
selfish positive is that there
our times that I am with someone might
be my family it might be friends and
getting recognized when I'm with someone
you know it gives you this little like
yeah I got recognized you know I'm
saying like you you you yeah it's it's
do it it's the sort of the self-centered
egotistical part of me responds to the
fact that hey I was in a group of people
and I got recognized and then there's a
look and then when you're with your
family someone that you care about their
opinion of you right and then you know
like if I'm with like my my mom gets
such a kick out of it right like my mom
will introduce herself my mom will be in
a conversation with somebody in public
and then just in the middle of the
conversation just throw out
do you know rhettandlink just so that
she could be like well rez my son right
you know so if I'm out in public and
then we get recognized like she gets a
kick out of that so I kind of get a kick
out of it well and my brother and his
boys recently came out spend some time
with us and we were we went we took them
down to the west side you know the only
time you go to the west side if you live
on the east side is when you've got
family in town you don't ever go all in
there go over there on your own volition
it's just like oh we got yeah we got
people in town let's show them let's
show em Los Angeles that we never see so
we went to talk in Santa Monica we went
to Santa Monica you talking Venice Beach
we didn't do Venice Beach I've done
Venice Beach with them but you know you
need that like what's the fight every
five years yeah so we were a Third
Street Promenade do you know the outdoor
a mall situation now there we go into
the Urban Outfitters because you know
it's different over there
I mean think god it just feels different
it's West Side know so we're going
through and then all sudden I realize
that there is a dog just a bulldog like
an American Bulldog are you about to
tell me you got recognized by a pole
yeah well that because that is a first
man there's an American Bulldog cats
that watch good mythical morning I hate
to tell you that but we get lots of
screen shots
I hats watching you think you get lots
of screenshots other people sent on me
all the time
but not a pretty much dog I appreciate
the views I mean
still it still adds to the ad revenue
even if it is a cat but the this
American Bulldog is walking around
without a leash in out Urban Outfitters
and I was like is this like is this what
they do on the west side they have like
mascots that roam roam the stores Lee's
tell me that he spoke English please and
then I hear someone say the dog's name
which I don't remember let's just say
spot which it wasn't spot get over here
and I look up in the the source of the
voice and ostensibly the owner of the
dog Dennis Quaid Dennis Quaid Dennis
Quaid now for those of you who don't
fully know who did ok you don't this is
that's what my stories okay cuz okay
okay so right Dennis Quaid is all I was
about to say was I can't answer that
exactly but Dennis Quaid was a very very
very famous movie star right like back
in the in the time of movie stars like
back when if you were in movies in the
80s it's a big freakin deal right like
there was celebrity culture was way way
smaller so he kind of comes from that
old guard
what's his biggest movie oh gosh can you
look that up but keep going he's been in
a bunch stuff
he continues to act he's like in a new
insurance campaign or whatever but oh
he's got on snakeskin boots first of all
which was impressive but so my brother
obviously gets a huge kick out of this
because he's 40 something year old man
and so obviously he knows who Dennis
Quaid is and we got a kick out of the
fact that Dennis Quaid
has a dog off leash in Santa Monica an
outfit which seems like the kind of
thing that you would feel like you had
the right to do if you were Dennis Quaid
you know what I'm saying it's like I
could do anything I was a movie star in
the 80s I can walk around with my dog
off the office leash I do have to tell
it to come to me over
again but at least would help with that
but Cole got a big kick out of it and
then he's literally saying kind of what
you were getting at cause like you know
not crazy like you come in here and you
see Dennis Quaid but you know like these
kids in here they probably more readily
recognize you than Dennis Quaid they
probably don't even know who Dennis
Quaid is yeah at literally five seconds
later a group of four teenage girls
walks by us and they're saying you know
why cuz he was in that the movie about
the dolphin girl Parent Trap he's in
Parent Trap yeah he was one that was the
remake of Parent Trap dolphin girl got
parents yeah I just saw Jacob held up
what's the dolphin girl where did the
the girl he's really not unless her leg
was Free Willy I mean she got a leg
bitten off by dolphin know by sure but
Sammy dolphin you mean the girl that
lost an arm she lost her arm to a ship
Soul Surfer or something yeah yeah yeah
yeah he's a dad in that yeah that's how
they know her know him no dolphins
involved but they know his name and they
you know what I'm saying like that means
they people want and then what about you
though well I will say that then they
did see me and they did they did it's
not as good of a story when they when
they recognize me but they did also
recognize me was that after you asked
him if they knew who you are I didn't I
did not approach them and I heard that
they saw me and then one of the girls
was like it's crazy we're seeing
everybody in here or something like that
like so anyway that Dennis Quaid men
shout out to Dennis that's if you want
to hang out at the dog park where you
don't need a leash the only appropriate
place where the dogs don't need to be on
a leash hit us up a lot of people like I
said at the top when they recognized me
like last night we were walking to meet
friends including you and Jesse at where
were we Highland Park yeah somebody
comes around the corner like
let me can i I know you can I take my
take a little video with you and I'm
like oh oh I'm always like we can just
grab a selfie but I didn't say that
that's interesting cuz I got that I got
a video request this video well and
usually they'll last like can you say so
and so does this person but instead he
just held it up like a selfie as if it
was a photo but he was doing video and I
waved like that's actually never
happened before and then he said does
this happen a lot and so whenever I'm
recognized I do get that follow up I do
think that like you said people want to
know if they're the only one that does
this or if they're maybe I guess if
they're am I being annoying because this
has happened five times as you rounded
the block so I guess I'll hanger that
question a little bit in the middle I I
think it's it does happen a lot and
basically every single time I go out now
it's multiple times I mean it's you know
I I had to run errands with with the
kids and I went to the grocery store and
then the drugstore next door and then we
got in the car and drove a block away
and went to like this pokeball place I
walked in the grocery store I got I got
recognized and then I went I was walking
out at the at the drugstore and I got
recognized and then we went to the
pokeball place and the guy working there
said something else that I've started to
get more frequently and that is the
question has anyone ever told you that
you look a lot like a guy from the
internet that happens quite a bit and so
what I say to that is I do get that a
lot actually and the reason why I say
that it's because like one of my kids is
usually with me and I like messing
around with people and like making them
feel like and and Lily was like dad this
is not this is not a heist no she said
that for the other for this thing she
said dad it is it is him don't he likes
to mess with people
because when we were I think I told the
story when we were in London at the
Harry Potter thing like these kids like
excuse me sir have you ever Tiny Tim has
ever been told oh you know like someone
from the internet I'm like yes exactly I
get it a lot that I look exactly like
someone from the internet exactly and I
kept saying that and they're like nodded
their heads and walked off
yeah then they came back later and got
pictures because I was in a confined
environment where we were all going
through a tour together yeah I mean
after it I should just say that like
it's freaking surreal to find yourself
walking around and just and and it's
happening I don't know I I don't know if
we're the most popular we've ever been
but it's happening more now than ever
like it continues to happen more and
more right I think it's the nature of
just the popularity of the medium like
more and more people are watching even
if you don't watch our videos you can't
escape our thumbnails yeah and so I
think and that brings me to a theory
about something else which I'm sure
we'll get into about what you hear
people saying a lot but well I don't
know if we're the most popular ever been
but we're the most visible and I guess
this is maybe they're the same thing
well and so it's happening a lot and I
just want to say I'm extremely grateful
because it's an indicator of things
working like oh our we create our stuff
to be seen yeah and so when people see
it and we get recognized more it's like
that's a good sign oh this is working
it's also freaking surreal because in my
innermost being I have a hard time
actually thinking of myself as a famous
person yeah like I it's like I don't
think of myself as an adult either a lot
of times I mean I know how my brain
works I know the thoughts and feelings
and processes I go through and I feel
like I might as well be a fourth grade a
lot of times you know not gonna test
them in a similar way I feel like I know
what faint I know who famous people are
I mean I've I've seen Parent Trap the
remake with Dennis Quaid
but I just don't feel like I'm one of
those people but you know what I guess I
am
well I recognized everywhere and I think
that that's the there's a few dynamics I
mean one is like you said is it's an
indicator so be grateful it can be a
little bit of a nuisance at times now in
the moment I'm never I think I want to
make this clear in the moment unless
somebody says or does something that is
particularly annoying which we'll get
into what I appreciate it and I don't
hold it in there's nothing against an
individual who comes up and recognizes
me but it's this the CID you sometimes
going into the situation knowing that it
could happen it's just a little that
that's what's annoying not the person
who did it but just the dynamic of that
the fact that it could happen for
instance we were coming back from
someplace and I was like I'd like to I'd
like to make some burger I can't
remember it was I think I was I wanted
to make some burgers and I'd like
watched a youtube video about like the
perfect skillet burger or whatever I was
like I'm gonna make these burgers with
this really nice beef or whatever and
just he's like okay well let's I don't
have any stuff so let's just go by the
grocery store and we pull out to the
grocery store and I'm like can you can
you go she was super tired she was like
I don't want to go in if you if you want
to cook this stuff you go in I was like
I don't want to go in because I just I
really don't wanna be recognized right
now it wasn't like I was having a bad
hair day or something it was just I was
like I just don't sometimes I get into
the grocery store and what you have to
have multiple interactions yeah but and
they have to they have to be for that
person you know every interaction you
have is for that person it's not for you
it's not you yeah I don't go into the
grocery store unless I'm taking some
press I guess you know well I don't go
into these places saying I wanna I want
to stop and have interactions yeah yeah
that are for that person to make them
sometimes you might be a lemon which I
want to talk about that but sometimes
you're and then I don't want to get
recognized mood because I just want to
get in and get out
and I know one would win I don't because
I want the interaction to be something
that is positive and memorable to this
person because I do care about anyone
who watches what we do enough to know
who we are I care about that person so I
don't know be an O to this person even
if I'm feeling particularly like Oh at
the time yeah but so Jessie was like
you're not gonna get recognized at the
grocery store like I choose just she was
basically trying to manipulate me so I
would be the one to go in because she
hands or her feet up on the dash oh she
did speaking a dirty - I know I need to
call dr. noodles buff out those Doc
Martin stains but not as not a sponsor
and I don't know I felt they need to say
what Braniff used my wife I don't at the
time oh I don't you're saying dr.
noodles not sponsored but he will be so
la can I go in together literally I walk
in to the grocery store and I'm like
where are the what do you call the
things carrying things baskets I was
like where the baskets at and the guys
like oh right over here you from good
mythical morning it's literally the
first guy that we talked to and luck
just got a kick out of because he was
like mom said you would get recognized
and then it happened yeah two more times
in the seven minutes that way I was
getting the three ingredients that I
needed again it wasn't it's not like it
was some big inconvenience but it was
just like again you feel like alright if
this person has a question they want to
get you I want to give them the time
that this is one chance that in it and
they want to have an interaction as
special or whatever right and so but I
just want to get burgers and go but so
but then there's the opposite end of the
spectrum which is I remember one time
our friend gar who we met Tony Hale
through and obviously Tony at this point
is like a huge star and would be
recognized basically anywhere that he
went
time he was pretty much known for
Arrested Development yeah and not veep
had not started but not started yet and
he wasn't like gonna be the frickin main
character in the upcoming Toy Story but
you up for that role or something why
did you get it my friend got more famous
cause I'm not angry no but in fact he if
anybody should get what he's gotten it's
in yeah so but gar said you know he was
joking cuz gar has this way of like
finding this thing out about you and or
assuming something about you in a way
that it's just funny right yeah yeah so
he was like you know sometimes Tony you
know whenever Tony needs a self
confidence boost he just goes to the
Apple store Arrested Development right
because the people who work at Apple or
and/or shop at Apple at the time the
gars joke was that there was a lot of
crossover those people were the Arrested
Development crowd and they would
recognize him now that he didn't
actually go to the Apple so he went to
the Apple store to get a product but
that was that was gars like a little
joke cause he was like any time he's
been with him an Apple store he's got
recognized so you might do this for self
confidence boost whenever we want to get
it self confidence boost we go to the
meat section in the rack that's right
that's where the mythical beasts hang up
no I was making statement or about us
and like our proclivity to eat but
butchered refuse but I will say so the
back of the butcher counter so those are
stuff they don't put out front those are
the two dynamics right there's the I'm
in a situation right now where I'm at
the airport I'm trying to move to a
location or I'm in an amusement park and
I don't want to suddenly have to get a
picture with somebody because that might
lead to this other person wanting a
picture and this other person wanting a
picture there were situations like that
where it's it seems like an
inconvenience and then there are times
where it's just like you know what and
this is never something that you think
but it's just like oh I'm with these
people right now
or I'm in this place right now right I'm
in this place that I think the people
here are particularly
cool or something I have some reason to
think that these P these people have a
particular taste and comedy boy be cool
to get recognized here and again this
isn't an actual conscious thought
process but this is sort of the
emotional undercurrent that is happening
from time to time because you remember
that when we where there are times when
we want to be recognized like I meant
I'm in this cook I'm in Melbourne
Australia and I think this is one of the
coolest places I've ever been
and if I feel like I'm in one of the
coolest places I've ever been is
somebody with a cool backpack meets me
on the the bridge going over the river
yeah and I get recognized even if they
don't know that we have a show that
night I can get over that because I'm
like oh that was a cool backpack I
really I like that person's taste in
backpacks and they like my show so hmm
there's a correlation there I'm cool
therefore I am right well you remember
so we were in New York and we were
somewhat Lower East Side or something
we're walking along and there are like
six to eight guys sitting on this stoop
and the basically like it feels like a
television show like it's like this is a
scene from a movie this isn't normal
this isn't like these it was nighttime
and it was a bit seedy ER then it then
like this wasn't network TV this was
like this could be like a scene in an
HBO see yeah yeah like the wire yeah but
it wasn't Baltimore it was New York it
said you got these guys had a sitting on
this stoop not seedy but gritty let's
say media and some guys who were sort of
embodying the grittiness of the area
shall we say right we were fish out of
water walking by we walk by we actually
get past them and all of a sudden a
guy's I hold up we might have even sped
up honestly rhett and Link and I'm like
what and then a guy who I'm just
describing him because this is he's
actually known on the internet for this
he calls himself
Rex I think he has a I think he's got an
Instagram but he does not have arms he
has hands he has he just has hands and
no arms and he he wears this as like a
badge of honor like he didn't have a
shirt on it's like it's his thing he has
fully embraced it
yeah and so he comes up to us and he's
like I'm big fan and he's like telling
the other guys in light another guy was
like yeah I know who they are whatever
and then I'm I was blown away I was like
this interesting combination of the
coolest guys who've ever recognized us
are saying that they know that they're
fans and then and then he explained who
he was and like how he like he puts on
like a t-rex head and goes around and
does t-rex emotions yeah Wow but though
but that was this thing that we talked
we talk about that all the time because
it was just like those guys watch yeah
we're in yeah it's wearing wearing each
other's orbit it's weird and cuz in a
cool way
and then again I know we've I feel like
we I want to constantly apologize for
we're just trying to be honest about the
way our thoughts work it's like I'm not
trying to be like oh look we could
recognize about cool people
I'm trying to explain the psyche of what
it does to you and what it could do to
us I could easily see how this could
become something that you sort of rely
on like an injection into your arm but
I'm saying so I think a healthier
response and is to you know if I'm going
to err on the side of something it's
being over it versus desiring it yeah so
I guess I take I guess it's a good sign
that like the struggle that we have is
being gracious and continuing to be
grateful
so being gracious to the person no
matter what they say if it's awkward or
if it's unintentionally insulting well
yeah we can hold a lot that's a whole
category we can get into that's a whole
category but then switching to being
gracious like I said and grateful so
like how we feel about it and so we can
land there in a few minutes I think but
and also talk about boundaries because
I'm starting to think about that and I
have one
story but before we do I do think that
it you know there are unintentionally
insulting things I think we've talked
about these before and it's just funny
it's not that we're actually no no I
don't know maybe go through one
situation where actually hurts or if
it's just kind of funny and that's why
we're talking yeah I don't I've told the
story before about the one time I was at
the airport and we were panicking we
missed a flight and somebody came up and
I think I was probably as short as I
have ever been with somebody but but the
tip I would say seven I don't think I'm
exaggerating seventy percent of the time
people say one of two things one is I
used to watch you all the time right and
the second thing is my fill-in-the-blank
cousin sister kid mom brother
it's the biggest fan somebody besides
somebody besides the person who's coming
up to you seventy so 70 and this is just
anecdotal but 70% of the time somebody
says something that it basically says
that me currently the one coming up to
you I'm not a fan I don't care I used to
care or somebody else cares right and so
that's some bothering you they'll tell
you that I'm not I'm not really into you
is it like is the worst interpretation
basically what I say every time is if
somebody says my so-and-so is a big fan
I'm like you're not I thought that's
what I say and then if somebody says I
used to watch it I'm like why'd you stop
because that's what I mean I'm not being
I'm not being a jerk I'm just yeah
legitimately like okay well it's a
little jerky I say if they say I used to
watch I'll say like the guy in the
pokeball place who like I had to wait
for the order so they end up talking to
it for like eight minutes but the
kickoff was I used to watch you after he
said has anyone told you you look like
God from the internet that I used to
watch I guess
and I'm like well we're still doing it
man and that's when it starts to feel
like yeah we're getting recognized more
but we got to all these people who are
recognizing us for not watching anymore
what does that mean we're falling off
and like it plays into my insecurities
and you know and
so that's not healthy but so Mike and
well Mike first of all I think if you're
talking about like our you know our
emotional state this is good this is
good right this is good it's I don't
want to be somebody who is constantly
like adulate it adulate it and built up
by other people because a it makes me
feel a little uncomfortable but also it
turns you into a jerk I mean like it's
very difficult if you are a just a
normal person even if you're normal
well-adjusted person who like this all
happened to us after we were fully
adults with kids married we got lots of
things in our lives that ground us but
even with all those things in place when
you comes if suddenly everyone is cares
about you because of something you did
and they and they want to be around you
or they want that can create problems
you can become a person that you no one
wants to be around so we're constantly
gardening against that but it helps when
70 percent of the time people recognize
you they're kind of insulting you well
the kids hi daebak it kind of balances
their obviously they're not
intentionally insulting us but I think
it's an insecurity that leads to it
being interpreted as an insult but it's
also a good thing it's also a positive
indicator that like our our work is
getting out there and again I want to
talk about our work and not talk about
us because that's what I want this to be
about it's the stuff that we create even
if we're this show whatever it's a sign
that it's getting out there to the point
where even if you don't watch it you
know about it like it's like people pay
millions in in marketing for just that
to happen awareness not even enjoyment
yeah you know awareness is arguably just
as powerful you notice I've got an
opinion about something that don't even
actively watch yeah you know when and I
think that's evidenced by the so you're
kind of talking about people that's a
good sign I don't aren't familiar and
and this is this is something that has
happened repeatedly that demonstrates
what you're talking about is definitely
the case that people just kind of kind
of know hey they don't know the name of
the show be they don't know who are
names but the most interesting and
funniest thing that's happened is I'll
be
with someone who is not you and gay this
most recently happened with my brother
same trip when he was in town and
somebody came up and they were like
uh-oh
you're you're that guy you're that guy
from the internet you know and I helped
him I was like yeah good mythical
morning and I'm like yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah and then my brother's with me and
they're like and you're the other guy
maybe my brother was like yeah your
brother so we got a picture right what's
why not the two of us got a picture with
this woman I run it what's that not been
like five times ironically was I not
like a block and a half away and we had
just split up to go in different stores
at that moment no that was a good day
was a different day does that happen
then to know someone got a picture with
you and that you didn't tell him that I
was across this yeah there was me yeah
yeah luck has a lot of that's a lot of
times people like where's Linc
and 99% of the time I'm like well I
don't know I don't have a geo tag on him
or whatever I have one on you so I tell
him exactly where you are that's why you
get recognized so much but in that
people going after you in that moment
you were literally on the opposite
street corner I was watching it happen
where's Linc I don't know why can't I
currently see him over your shoulder but
I'm not gonna I'm not gonna SiC him on
you sometimes I like to if people are
taking a picture with you I like to
sneak up at the last second and get in
the photo kind of like how really famous
people do when they're like in the
Marvel Universe and then they they show
up and sneak into photos well and that
because you know what you were talking
about what I don't feel again I I
watched that documentary about Bill
Murray which by the way isn't I don't
know if I could recommend it because I
was kind of annoyed by the filmmaker and
I just didn't like the way the film was
made but I really like Bill Murray and I
really like these stories about people
he shows up he shows up and he does
these things and he's built I
we're not Bill Murray and but I also
have this abiding sense that I can't I
couldn't ever do that because I'm just
guy from the internet there may be some
circles that if I showed up me and you
showed up he would be a big deal for
people but for the majority
people there's one person in the group
who knows who we are and then everyone
else starts asking why you kick who who
are those guys and then people start
asking us oh that's the work that
happened in a coffee shop the other day
we were down in Seal Beach
where Locke had some basketball games
and he had like a game in the afternoon
than a game at night so we had all this
time to kill while walking around going
to this coffee shop all these seals to
kill what did you say time to kill okay
at Seal Beach okay better did not kill
any seals did you see any do you have a
colossi misnomer I show up when you have
a club I go into the coffee shop and the
girl working the register is like oh hey
uh a big fan of your show and we had a
pleasant interaction that's perfect and
then an older woman who was in line
behind me she was like well what do you
do oh gosh this happens quite a bit I
hate having to explain what I do to
people who don't actually care ever
since I had a few dozen times I was like
I got a show I got a show on the
Internet
that you know what do you do on the show
like that conversation that annoys me
okay in all the things that happen with
getting recognized that is the thing
that annoys me the most is you're making
me tell you why someone that so what I
what I do now whether it's a child who
recognizes me and the parents are like
why do they I say I feel like it's even
worth with the parents because they have
a relationship with the person who knows
us so that could be an easy way to have
a conversation
it was worse when I leaned over I turned
to the girl who was waiting on me the
cash register and I said she'll tell you
all about it so that's what I do now
it's like what do you do I say well ask
her I and I I mean I know that I'm
putting that person in a situation but
and I know that I'm kind of seeming like
a complete jerk now and I've told you
that the way I respond to these things
but it happens I just had these sort of
back pocket responses for people I used
to watch why'd you stop it may I make a
suggestion
I think if you tweak your language a
little bit it can be a little more
self-deprecating like if instead of sent
will at ask her even with the up and I
say it nice look I know you say it
nicely but you could go step further and
you could say something like I think it
would be better hearing it from her and
it's well I think the John he's
embarrassed to talk about what he does
he must be a porn star I think the tone
of I say you know I got her I say then
she's afraid to ask
I say it's a in a joking way and
although all those responses I know
so I say she'll tell you all about it
and then it usually just results in no
one saying anything else and I just get
my coffee and start drinking it yeah
that's I don't like that either I when
the parent it's like asking multiple
questions to figure out why the kid
likes us I mean you know well it'd be
one thing if it was like I'm an actor
you know it's like right right it's hard
to explain if I tell you I'm a youtuber
you'll have a question about that right
then if I tell you what I do on YouTube
you'll have a question about that right
and then you'll just be like I don't why
is my child a family it's the same
principle as if you do get a selfie with
somebody in like an amusement park or a
crowded area like a mall or something
then there is a chance that like a
little line will form which brings me to
I think the biggest sensitivity to this
whole thing is being out with our
families you know because it it really
puts a wrench you know we don't make
public plans as a family that involves
adding you know 10 percent margin to
accommodate for you know us being
stopped me being stopped and then having
to separate from me so that they won't
be in the photo all right you know yeah
and then so it I think it's very it it
really tests their patience and I fully
understand that or do i I was at you
know we we went to the Shazam movie
premiere and they they had it was
thrilling like we didn't Instagram
stories like
had SH and Oh with me and like you were
in the fares will with my wife by the
way
right no I was with my who are you your
wife and your daughter we're in it we're
in the fares well different different
cards okay and she's afraid of heights
so like I wanted to watch her be in that
ferris wheel but I was I'm glad you
weren't there in such a tender moment
did she have a difficult time I think
she did great she / she overcame some
sort of ferris wheel fear they freaking
shut down the Hollywood Boulevard and
set up a whole carnival and then that it
was just invite only and you know
fortunately we got it we got in on that
and we're walking around getting free
fair food and all this stuff and then
Christie's like turns to Lilly when I'm
standing there she's like look it's
sterling K Brown one of the stars of
this is us the show that even mentioning
it makes you cry they both love this
show and they bonded over it and I know
the guys i'ma watch the show of course
we had the other guy from this is us on
good mythical morning Chris Sullivan
absolutely anyway
sterling has not been on our show we had
never met him but when my wife and my
daughter are talking about how much of a
connection they make with the show and
they're like geeking out and like I
actually think that Kristy I'm gonna I'm
gonna pull her under the bus with me
here I do think she said maybe we could
get a picture he's sitting right there
he and his son who is like grade
schooler we're like enjoying some fair
food on a bench and we're standing there
whispering about him and I'm like I just
was like oh I'll ask him for a photo
okay and I go up there and I'm like
sterling how you doing and I shook his
hand I look like I'm link um I just want
to let you know and boy as I'm telling
this there's a lot of faux pas here that
we've discussed the first thing he said
was my wife used to be a fan my wife and
daughter are huge fans would you mind if
I snapped a photo
so again I was like I'm not I feel like
keep going but I feel like that's
different okay it is because they were
there that yeah it is different and I'm
not annoyed by it I'm just saying it's
just the case that most people say that
and Sterling Kay Brown said no his his
face changed to this apologetic yet kind
I can make you cry at will on television
face he said this is really family time
for me and my son so I'm just gonna I'm
gonna need to pass or he said I don't
know if he said I'm gonna need to pass
but he said something like as the most
gracious way I was like hmm I'm gonna
write that down and then I walked away
like totally I felt like a total jack
for asking him for the photo and then I
turn around and I yelled at Christy and
Lilly in front of everybody look what
you made me do
no I didn't I was like he's have a
family time and I was like and then it
like clicked for them too and they're
like all three of us it clicked in our
minds I think at that moment it's like
wait I bet I bet we could have that too
you know it was like hey we could have
family time the table's turned where it
was like what if learning from my mentor
Stirling K Brown I adopted a similar
mantra when it came to I'm out I'm out
in public but I'm having special time
with my my wife and my kids this is a
difficult one I don't I respected him
totally I just felt it's I don't I don't
I have no judgment of him and by the way
I felt bad for asking him I felt like
you talked to him the other night at
that thing he did not recognize we went
to we went to a party and he was there
and we might tell more the details that
party later so I want to save it okay
except for the fact that like I shook
his hand and I like looked in his eyes
and I was like is he gonna recognize me
as that guy like no him sure wouldn't he
did now even though it was me and
Christy there this is interesting
because okay at that same
at that same cuz I want to talk about
these boundaries that's what I'm looking
at the same premier a number of people a
ten I don't know
came up and asked to get pictures they
got pictures with us and some people
like one of them was it was a mom she
came up and she was like my son is a
huge fan and he was there and she and
and turns out he was in the freakin
movie he was one of the kids in the
family and Shazam yeah and we in that I
think two things are going on number one
we don't see ourselves at on the level
of sterling sterling K Brown right I
know there's some people were like
that's ridiculous there's no difference
between what you do and what well I'm
just telling you that I I see him as a
real celebrity and I see myself as a
youtuber and I know that's I'm selling
the whole platform short by saying that
but just mentally because anybody can
make a youtube video not anybody can
just go and say I'm on an episode of
this is us you can make your own show on
YouTube just as easily as we can so it
just feels like it's arcane you it's it
feels like there's a there's different
thing going on maybe he has experience
well if I come to like I'm bringing my
kid to this thing and if I get a picture
with one person it would lead to a
picture would and all of a sudden this
is about me and not about my son so I
completely understand that but for me in
the end when we were this is Shazam
premiere I always feel like we should
don't really we shouldn't be there
imposter syndrome I'm like how did we
how it's just two guys from North
Carolina who just kind of got lucky and
ever done that nobody knows that were
just a couple of dumb rednecks and we've
put with that just not a put hair
product in and maybe if sterling hey
brown sees us get a picture of somebody
then something will maybe we can be
friends with it exactly and so when
you're in this mode oh yeah I got to
admit like it's like oh there's other
real celebrities here if somebody wants
a picture with me that they there's that
dynamic and so but sterling Brown okay
Brown is not thinking about it like that
he's not he isn't trying to impress
anybody right and so I guess when he get
you get to this centered balanced place
you can say things like I'm having a
family time right now so I'm gonna have
to pass and you say that without apology
so are you now saying that that is what
you're gonna say when you're with your
family I think I'm going to when I go
into certain situations like if it's if
it's a special event that I'm bringing
one of my kids to because they are
particularly excited about that and it
is about hey I'm bringing you to this
thing we're talking about it and there's
a build up to it and then we get there
and there's like I'm spending 10 percent
of my time taking photos with people I
think that that sends it's it's a missed
opportunity to send a message to that
child that like you're the priority and
this is about you this is not about me I
think we've just broken down the
psychology of what selfies could mean to
us in a situation like that and I think
that so I'm not saying across the board
but I'm saying I'm gonna choose I'm
gonna try to choose going into events
like a mindset of of doing that like
especially if this if there's a if
there's a if it's an enclosed space
where there's a lotta people that could
be fans that's the invite I think the
environment is a big deal if you're
walking through another leads to another
if you're just walking down the street
with your family having family time and
somebody's like hey can I get a picture
like that's a 10 second interaction or
whatever it's not they they're if they
want to start talking and they have a
bunch of questions it made that point
maybe like I'm sorry I you know I'm
really I'm with my family now and I'm
people are still gonna think you're a
jerk for doing it just so you know
because people could be like why can't
he just give me a minute
that's just wait people are like you you
are actually took a very mature
perspective on the way that you
responded to sterling came around and
you're only able to do that because you
can relate but if somebody couldn't
relate they would just be like he's kind
of a jerk for doing that they would
go to the next step and be like oh
that's sweet that he's doing that for
its kid because there's a dynamics that
people don't understand going on so I do
think that the environment is really
important if I'm just out in the middle
of somewhere where there's it's not like
all of a sudden a crowd could form or
somebody else I'm gonna I'm gonna say
okay sure let's do a quick photo or
whatever but I do think that if it's
situated like amusement parks are the
are the supreme situation because you're
there for your family to have a good
time and one recognition and one picture
leads to more and then it becomes yeah I
the first time I went to Disneyland with
my kids right when people were starting
to recognize us
I ruined their day it let it ruin their
day right
and I was trying to be nice and I'm like
oh yeah I'm the approachable guy from
YouTube yeah of course you can get a
picture with me
and that turned into I've got to get a
hat I've got to get a hat in sunglasses
and then I was felt like when those
douches walking around with I had it I'm
wearing a hat and sunglasses at
Disneyland so you won't recognize me can
I get a picture with you because I've
never seen someone so douche like but I
reduced level is so high I ruined my
family's day so I so I do think that you
kind of have to evaluate the environment
and then you have to have like I'm sure
he said that line I'm sorry I'm having a
family time right now so I'm gonna have
to pass he's he's worked on that line
yeah and may he's made it as on you know
disarming as possible sterling Cade
disarmament that's what I'm gonna be
doing from now on yeah I think that's
helpful I think I think that's a good
stopping point you know food for thought
I think this has been beneficial for us
I don't know what it's done for you but
thanks for hanging in there hopefully it
has it made you incredibly nervous about
if you see this in public I don't know
what to do now that they talked about it
like this just be yourself
just be yourself be yourself and
evaluate the the environment will be
doing the same thing
yeah but it's on us to set the boundary
you know leave that to us we will crush
you know you have a wreck for us oh yeah
as a reward for hanging on so long give
you a recommendation
um check baby check baby 1 2 3 4 baby
erect you know what I'd like to
recommend going over and perusing it may
be participating in the good mythical
morning and rhett and Link reddit
threads subreddits in the occasional
times that I go through there I'm
encouraged about the thoughtful
exchanges that are happening around our
content so check that out and then if
you want more relational and even deeper
interactions with people other mythical
beasts then of course I'll tack on a
recommendation for becoming a member of
the mythical society but yeah I like the
I'm encouraged by the tone and the the
thoughtfulness of the exchanges on
reddit and you might if you haven't been
there you might be pleasantly surprised
in lurking and then joining in so those
two subreddits so there you have it well
thank you for joining us once again we
will be doing the same thing just
slightly different we'll be talking
about something different but the same
two guys sitting at the same table in
the same formation links voice maybe a
little bit different because you won't
have a color anymore
hashtag air biscuits let us know what
your thoughts are and don't be afraid to
let it shine if the Sun is hardened then
your teeth can make the difference in
someone's life
just smile a little smile and brighten
the environment so that's an original
right we don't have to pay anybody for
that I think that was painfully obvious
yes I went to you know I was it I was at
lunch yesterday are you done yet I'm not
done oh and this one I could tell that I
got recognized by someone who was seated
with us and then they were seated
further down and me and Chris are on a
date and the whole time in the back of
my mind I knew that there was this like
these people who recognized me were you
know they were fans like it was a little
more like giddy fan energy and so like
I've learned to deal with the fact that
like okay I know I'm being watched right
now even though I'm on a date yep it's
like there was a couple of years there
where it was like that did a number on
me but I think I'm over that but I
thought this was gonna end with I went
and set with him we got a picture
afterward like we ended up leaving at
the same time and they were they were
waiting outside for me to come out so at
least I didn't approach me at the table
so I thought that was a nice boundary
but it was weird cuz it you know you
ever feel like you've been watched when
you're on a date and it's actually much
easier than people realize for you to
notice that they've noticed you and you
don't even have even though I'm a
Bolivia's right thank goodness I'm
oblivious you noticed twice as much as I
do I have a great vantage point okay now
we're done
to watch more ear biscuits click on the
playlist on the right to watch the
previous episode of your biscuits click
on the playlist to the left and don't
forget to click on the circular icon to
subscribe if you prefer to listen to
this podcast it's available on all your
favorite podcast platforms thanks for
being your mythical best
[Music]